it's really hard sometimes Bachelorette
Hannah brown
reveals hindsight is 20/20 when it comes
to contestant Luke P et spoke with the
former beauty queen at CMA fest in
Nashville Tennessee on Friday where she
opened up about last week's dramatic
luke s versus luke p fight it's really
hard sometimes to watch back the show
because I mean especially and that it's
it's you know there are certain things
that I don't get to see and I'm not
previewed to see I mean I only get what
the conversation that I have with each
of the guys and so it is sometimes
difficult to believe so that's actually
what happened
I mean it was a little upsetting but you
know that is something that I knew that
I just wanted to be able to really just
figure everything out for myself and
you'll you'll see me do that I take the
information that I'm giving in and I
just trust throughout the process that I
will be able to make my own decisions
with the information I'm getting in my
discernment in my own time and there
definitely is chemistry between weepy
and I and
that is something that is worth looking
into and in my chemistry with him is
much stronger than maybe somebody else
other men there and that's something
that I'm going to investigate why my
feelings were that way even if he does
have issues in the house and I just have
to figure out exactly where those issues
are rooted but I'm not like a Burin
getting to see all the different things
that are happening in the house our
relationship it's a big part of my
journey and how I decide to really just
trust my gut and how I feel about a
relationship and what I do to decide you
know how I want to continue on I think
it's really hard for anybody to know
just like what it's like to be on this
side and like even for me I mean I've
had eyes things on my family and I wish
I wouldn't have said that last season or
even now my god I could have said that
differently but you know you this is a
really hard position to the end where
you can see you at your vestment your
worst and you have to be able to deal
with that but ultimately you said those
things we did this thing you have to
take ownership of that and I think it's
really important to take ownership of
everything that you do learn from and
said with Luke he was with anybody and
with myself I just hope that this is a
learning this new user we can all
integrate with speaking of taking
ownership Jen admitted that he came on
to some of his music career hmm how did
that make you feel what are you feeling
just like I've ultimately said on the
episode I mean when the guy walks in
with a guitar I mean they're notorious -
you always are suspect or something but
I really all I've wanted was somebody to
be honest and real with me and he was
back and so he did exactly what I asked
for him to do it so I admired that and I
have a strong connection with Jed and so
for me that was really important to hear
from his mouth that hey this is why I
came on because ultimately those guys
knew it was really me that was
to be the lead when they signed up for
the show so for him to say hey I didn't
know who's gonna be this is why I came
on the show but now I really do have
feelings for you and that was good for
that that I feel like was even harder to
do and I appreciate it and I felt like
it was like all right we've got that Cup
I already kind of knew so now we can
send us on a relationship are you in a
relationship and are you least happy I
can tell you
[Music]